well here's a really cool story because
the natural world is obviously the best
and most beautiful and interesting place
a fishing boat just got caught in a
massive Shark Feeding Frenzy off the
coast of Louisiana the fishermen were on
the search for yellowfin tuna and Wahoo
when dozens of sharks all of a sudden
came around their boat feeding on a bait
ball and it's just an unbelievable
series of pictures watch this
perfect
Mark Hardesty is the captain of the boat
money shot he's one of the people who
was there that day he joins us now Mark
that's it I don't know how long you've
been on the water but have you ever seen
anything like that in your life
well not to this degree where they just
came up under the boat like they did uh
we've seen it many times though uh
because the shark population in the
north central Gulf has exploded kind of
like a cockroach infestation and it is
just dramatically increased and it is
decimated uh a lot of the food fish and
is working on the the game fish that are
are so prevalent in Venice Louisiana
because the federal restrictions under
the Magnus and Stevens act have really
done a toll on the fishery and it's
certainly a over regulation situation
that's going on now
Washington is not good at managing the
natural world I've noticed um so I mean
I hope they're not going after redfish
and and are they and why do you think
the shark population has exploded
well the shark population we believe is
exploded because of the um the
restrictions on Commercial Fishing quite
frankly and fishing in federal waters
shark fishing is still allowed in state
waters and that puts that puts really no
dent in it in comparison to what's going
on offshore and in the Gulf it's nine
miles an hour or state or federal waters
and then nine miles in or statewaters
so when you see a Feeding Frenzy over a
bait ball like this and you're on a boat
it's a you know decent sized boat four
engines but it's still an Open Boat do
you do you have fantasies about falling
in
well certainly it crosses your mind but
I'm in a pretty seaworthy boat I was in
a 37 Freeman which is a very uh
seaworthy boat and uh so there wasn't
that much concern about that aspect of
things but certainly they were so froth
up in this frenzy that uh you know
certainly there's something that crosses
your mind that one launches themself
into the boat
luckily that didn't occur and
unfortunately this is just occurring
more and more I've noticed an
exponential uh increase in shark
activity in the Gulf over the last five
or six years and what that's shown is is
that the Magnus and Stevens act has
essentially the harm that it has caused
is simply been in place long enough to
really start dramatically increasing the
population of these sharks
yeah I think people who understand
nature should have a voice in the
management of of our natural world but
of course you don't unfortunately mark
artisty thank you so much for joining us
tonight I appreciate it thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight